to notice the ladies we have just seen  are unforgettable players to me they are  more than that  they are friends at the risk of the  increasing the suspense for our friends  I'd like to moment just to say something  the conventional wisdom is that you're  born with talent  maybe that's so but talent is unusable  and wasted without work dedication and a  deep feeling for others the truly  talented ladies nominated for Best  Performance by an actress are Liza  Minnelli in cabaret Diana Ross and Lady  Sings the Blues Maggie Smith and  traveled with my aunt Cicely Tyson and  sounder leave Ullman in the immigrants  and the winner is what they haven't got  a cause  Liza Minnelli  making the film of cabaret was one of  the happiest times of my whole life and  I would like to thank everybody  connected with it but most especially  the artistic staff mr. Fauci and Fred  ebb and John Kander and thank you for  giving me this award you've made me very  happy